[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week-end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 9 avril
quel bilan après les quatre jours de
classe en distance yale avant les
vacances scolaires confie mais quelle
organisation après les congés
et quid du bac pour les lycéens nous
ferons le point aussi bien avec les
parents d'élèves qu'avec les enseignants
nos invités delphine romani du syndicat
snes fsu 78 et manuela affonso quand
celle de l'association de parents
d'élèves la peep de montigny le
bretonneux la crise sanitaire empêche
également de fêter son anniversaire
normalement les yvelines où année au
mois d'avril ne sont pas gâtés avec le
premier confinement 2020 ils ont déjà
fêté un premier anniversaire confiné et
il en sera de même cette année
témoignage m enfin rencontre avec un
chocolatier de versailles depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire
la profession tire son épingle du jeu
nous verrons son portrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une semaine de cours en distance yale
pour l'ensemble des élèves français et
des établissements scolaires vient de
s'achever c'était la décision prise par
emmanuel macron pour répondre à la crise
sanitaire juste avant les vacances
scolaires qui démarre ce vendredi 9
avril au soir
et ce pour deux semaines autre
particularité cette année le calendrier
des vacances scolaires a été un petit
peu chamboulé pas de zones à b ou c pour
ces vacances de pâques mais bien deux
semaines unifié pour l'ensemble des
élèves français pour parler de ces
mesures mais aussi de l'organisation du
baccalauréat 2021 à venir nous
accueillons un visio conférence avec
nous delphine rhmani bonsoir bonsoir à
vous êtes secrétaire départemental du
syndicat snes fsu 78 également avec nous
par visioconférence manuela à fond au
cancer bonsoir bonsoir
et vous vous êtes la présidente de
l'association de parents d'élèves la pep
de montigny le bretonneux
tout d'abord première question delphine
romani quel bilan faites vous de ces
quatre jours de cours à distance on le
sait il ya eu de nombreux bugs notamment
sur la plateforme internet
ent espace numérique de travail personne
ne pouvait se connecter comment ça s'est
passé pour vous je viens écouter je
crois que c'est à l'image de ce qu'ont
vécu beaucoup d'enseignants savions on
peut le dire qui est catastrophique
contrairement à ce qui est annoncé
depuis des mois rien n'était prêt
donc comme beaucoup d'enseignants et
bien à mardi il était quasiment
impossible d'avoir accès aux différents
environnements numériques de travail je
sois l'humanité ou aux pour les collèges
la plateforme du cned fonctionner
également
donc je crois que les enseignants et
comme les élèves ont vécu plusieurs
jours de grand stress de prendre fatigue
et de désemparement face à tous ces
dysfonctionnements avec nous ont
vraiment empêché de maintenir le lien
avec les élèves dont quatre jours
compliqués en tant que parent d'élève
comment avez vous vécu vos aussi ces
quatre jours de distance yale de l'autre
côté finalement alors de l'autre côté de
la barrière on va être honnête il ya eu
une période de grande solitude justement
liée à ses problèmes techniques
principalement sur mon tennis était
principalement lié aux classes
virtuelles du cned mais également d
humanité ça a réveillé les inquiétudes
liées à la continuité pédagogique de
l'année dernière on a commencé à se
demander s'il allait pas falloir être
tout aussi adaptable
finalement la situation a fini par se
résorber les équipes de professeurs et
des établissements ont fait un super
travail même s'ils ont été obligés dans
la majorité des cas d'utiliser des
plateformes de l'homologuer ils ont
quand même réussi à faire ce qu'il
fallait pour créer le lien
après honnêtement on reste on reste dans
une ambiance assez anxiogène déjà parce
que nos enfants l'école à la maison
c'est pas optimale dans le sang tout ils
sont dans leur environnement personnel
ils ne sont pas dans une optique de
travail et les parents étant en
télétravail généralement bah c'est pas
compatible on ne peut pas télétravailler
et s'occuper de l'éducateur struction de
nos enfants malgré la disponibilité des
professeurs ça devient compliqué autant
pour les plus jeunes que pour les moins
jeunes du coup comme je disais ça y est
c'est les vacances à partir de ce
vendredi soir elle démarre ce soir du
coup pour tous les élèves français c'est
une première à l'origine dans les
yvelines ces vacances de pâques devaient
débuter le samedi 17 avril
manuela afonso quand celle comment vous
êtes vous organisé avec vos enfants
comment les parents d'élèves
s'organisent avec leurs enfants
pour ces vacances anticipées dans les
yvelines en fait ce qu'on peut on avait
tous fait des plans pour les vacances à
l'origine cet orgue
les grands parents s'est organisée
pourquoi pas les envoyer en colonie de
vacances ou enfin juste pour une semaine
ou des choses comme ça les centres de
loisirs pareil on avait fait des
organisations là le problème c'est que
les protocoles sanitaires et les
fermetures des établissements à laisse
encore planer des flous je pense
principalement pour l'accueil collectif
qui peuvent centre de loisirs on n'a pas
encore toutes les données
tous ces informations sur dans quelle
mesure les enfants seront accueillis
pour les plus grandes a écouté ils vont
faire comme ils font d'habitude un ils
vont ils vont essayer d'organiser des
sessions de deux rencontres ni vu ni
connu
par le biais de leurs réseaux sociaux et
puis nous on va essayer d'être le plus à
l'affût possible pour pour les protéger
mais en soi oui l'organisation a été
bouleversé il faut qu'on s'adapte et
bombarde
on sait ce qu'on peut avec ce qu'on a
quoi côté enseignants comment ça s'est
passé avec le programme scolaire
delphine romani ou une semaine de moins
du coup au niveau du calendrier alors
effectivement encore une fois ça a été
ça a été très compliqué puisque on l'a
dû tous dans la précipitation
reprogrammé nos cours une première fois
avec l'annoncé précipitée des vacances
il va falloir les reprogrammer une
seconde fois puisque tout comme toutes
les plateformes dysfonctionné rien de ce
qui avait été reprogrammé n'a pu se
faire et vraiment je crois qu'il faut
aussi souligner celle impréparation
totale de ces décisions
le snes fsu au niveau national à
apporter dès la rentrée 2020 des
propositions ministre pour que plusieurs
scénarios puisse être anticipée le
ministre était dans le refus de répondre
à ses demandes
il était pris dans un dogme qui était de
ne surtout pas fermer les écoles rien
prévoir ne rien anticipé et gentil je
crois que les enseignants et surtout les
élèves et des parents d'élèves paient
les pots cassés de cette politique qui
est totalement dans la prévision à la
précipitation deux semaines de repos
donc mais reprise des cours le 26 avril
prochain
pas pour tout le monde en revanche les
maternelles et primaires vont réinvestir
les établissements scolaires mais pour
les collégiens et les lycéens
ce sera une semaine plus tard ils auront
donc à nouveau une semaine de cours à
distance retour en présentiel le 3 mai
cette année c'est aussi là
nouvelle formule du bac + 2 filières l
es ou ou est ce un grand oral aussi est
ce qu'il y ait des inquiétudes par
rapport à la préparation de cette
épreuve importante pour pour les lycéens
au sein des parents d'élèves du 78 à huy
l'inquiétude en fait et surtout liée à
cette préparation du grand oral et des
difficultés
enfin en fait on n'a pas de visibilité
sur la manière dont les choses vont
s'organiser avec le distant ciel de
semis présentiel et tous les trucs en
vielle le protocole qui évoluent tous
les quatre matins on est vraiment dans
le dans l'instantanéité et cette
instantanéité nous fait juste titre nous
inquiéter sur les méthodes de
préparation après encore une fois on a
quand même confiance aux professeurs de
faire dans les professeurs de nos
enfants on accueille lyon confiance dans
l'organisation qui va se mettre en place
même si on est bien conscient que c'est
s'il ya encore une fois on sait de
l'adaptabilité à tous les niveaux mais
l'inquiétude est présente d'autant plus
qu'on a peur de la création d'une
génération coheed au niveau du diplôme
et voilà c'est surtout ça le sujet
d'inquiétude c'est quelle sera la valeur
du diplôme de nos enfants et dans
quelles conditions est ce qu'ils vont
être préparés à le passer avec tout ce
qui se passe en effet l'année dernière
je le rappelle c'était déjà une année
entre guillemets bac qu'ovide en
contrôle continu
côté enseignants comment on s'organise
entre cette nouvelle version du bac la
crise sanitaire ses cours à distance
comment on s'organise et écoutez c'est
vrai que c'est assez compliqué et
surtout ce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
c'est qu'un certain de lycée depuis le
mois de novembre sont déjà passés à une
partie de distance yale
donc ce qui a permis évidemment de voilà
d'alléger les effectifs de mieux
respecter les protocoles sanitaires ça
serait protecteur mais ça a également
généré d'énormes inégalités entre les
élèves puisque il n'y a eu aucun cadrage
d'union nationale dans chaque
établissement s'est organisée il a
souhaité dont dans certaines matières
ont été supprimés dans certains
établissements va supprimer je veux dire
évidemment suivi à distance elle
d'autres ont pu avoir lieu
c'est très différent selon les lycées
donc ça nous préoccupe vraiment que
aucun aménagement n'a été prévu pour ce
grand oral qui est marrant comme si rien
ne s'était passé comme si tous les
élèves avaient subi les mêmes
enseignements qui est très très très
loin d'être le cas
on s'inquiète aussi sur les modalités
passer un grand oral à distance comme le
disait dit madame alfonso de la paix
c'est oublier que tous les élèves ne
dispose pas d'un équipement numérique
donc on ne voit pas comment cela va
s'organiser et respecter l'équité de
traitement devant l'examen et puis on
est inquiet aussi évidemment de cette
génération d'élèves qui qui a déjà pâti
du confinement l'année dernière quand il
à la prochaine rentrée pas être une
génération d'étudiants qui n'aura
quasiment jamais passer un examen merci
delphine romani je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire départemental snes fsu
78 et merci aussi à vous manuela affonso
cansell présidente de la pec de montigny
le bretonneux d'avoir été avec nous pour
ce 7,8 week end et la crise de
sanitaires impact aussi la célébration
des anniversaires depuis un an
avec ce troisième confinement qui
courent sur le mois d'avril
pour certains ce sera leur second
anniversaire confiné rencontre avec deux
yvelinoise qui passe une nouvelle fois
une fête un peu particulière c'est en
petit comité et en respectant les gestes
barrières que sophie schmidt a fêté son
anniversaire cette année le 3 avril 2020
pendant le premier confinement c'est en
solitaire qu'elle avait passé sept jours
nuit quand j'ai appris que à nouveau on
était art confiné de manière un peu plus
strictes j'ai vraiment été contrariés la
dernière c'était pire parce que là on
n'avait vraiment pas le droit de se
déplacer même mes enfants qui sont donc
dans un autre cas type quartier de
versailles ne sont pas venus donc on a
fait ça en visio ce 3 avril 2021 en
plein troisième confinement seule la
famille étaient conviés à un déjeuner
couvre-feu oblige en moindre mal pour
fêter comme il se doit ses 54 ans on a
invité mes enfants qui habitent
versailles dans un autre quartier ma
mère qui est du chesnay et puis mes
nièces aussi qui sont leurs sayez à
houdan julia bientôt quatre ans va elle
aussi connaître son deuxième
anniversaire qu'on finit le 15 avril
la petite fêter ses trois ans et
évidemment cette célébration a été
quelque peu adapté nous avons fait un
petit goûter d'anniversaire le jour même
avec les bougies le gâteau et le soir
même nous avons re fêter l'anniversaire
re souffler les bougies avec un nouveau
gâteau d'autres cadeaux et en mettant en
fait le système de visio avec papa mamie
et mamou le 15 avril prochain julia
fêtera son anniversaire avec son papa et
le week end avec sa maman une façon de
garder un peu de normalité
bien que les grands parents qui vivent
dans d'autres régions ne puisse venir
le plus dur pour elle c'est l'absence
des papys mamies et papys maman parce
que elle a vraiment cette notion de fête
avec sa famille et ça c'est plus dur
pour elle de vivre que ce soit à houdan
ou à versailles en 2020 ou en 2021
question cadeaux là aussi il a fallu
s'adapter à des cadeaux puisque
merci la poste il envoie des colis ça ça
aide beaucoup pour recevoir les cadeaux
à l'année dernière c'est vrai que j'ai
pas aimé k2 forcément en temps et en
heure ce qu'on n'était pas habité
finalement acheté en ligne
cette année c'est vrai que ils ont fait
des achats dans les boutiques du
quartier qui était ouverte dombasle
libraire fleuriste un nom de crise
sanitaire écoulée et deux anniversaires
confinés comme beaucoup d'autres
yvelinois toutes deux ont désormais un
souhait pour l'année prochaine célébrer
leur naissance
sans être confiné le reste de
l'actualité de la semaine c'est justin
brasier qui nous le résume en 78
secondes une semaine marquée par le
retour des cours à la maison pour les
écoles collèges et lycées après
l'annnonce de cette fermeture mercredi
31 mars les professeurs ont dû
s'organiser pour faire classe via des
plateformes en ligne mardi gérald
darmanin est allé à la rencontre de la
police nationale au commissariat de
sartrouville
lors de sa visite le ministre de
l'intérieur a annoncé l'arrivée de 16
nouveaux policiers d'ici le mois de
septembre après trois semaines de blocus
le domaine de grignon a été libéré par
les étudiants d'agroparistech une
occupation réalisé en opposition à la
vente du site historique située à
tilleur val grignon l'entreprise
dunlopillo soutenu par le département
près de 2 millions d'euros ont été
avancées par les yvelines un budget
permettant aux nouveaux repreneurs pin
hadorn de ne pas payer les murs de sa
structure
en création à l'aérodrome de toussus le
noble un fab lab de l'avion électrique
vient de recevoir une subvention de 250
mille euros une aide de la région ile de
france pour acquérir deux avions
électriques
enfin depuis le 27 mars le domaine de
dampierre a rouvert ses portes au public
les 90 hectares de jardins sont de
nouveau accessibles pour se balader en
plein air
[Musique]
et il y a une semaine c'est aussi pâques
pour l'occasion rencontre avec un
chocolatier depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire la profession tourne à plein
régime
ce métier est l'un des rares qui a su
tirer son épingle du jeu
exemple à la reine astrid à versailles
celle et agathe son goût a rencontré
christophe bertrand artisan chocolatier
depuis 2008 riz soufflé manque de
basilic ou encore michèle ganascia ces
petits carrés de chocolat ont la cote en
ce moment même si la semaine de pâques
représente 10% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel
le chocolat se vend très bien depuis un
an c'est essentiel au chocolat toute
façon il ya du magnésium il ya là de la
théobromine qui en espèces d'excitant il
ya puis voilà et puis c'est vrai qu'on
mange du chocolat quand on n'a pas trop
le moral donc c'est la période s'y prête
malheureusement christine bertrand a
repris la marque et la reine astrid en
depuis huit boutiques ont vu le jour en
ile de france le chef furent reste cette
petite boutique implantée à versailles
la crise sanitaire a épargné ce
chocolatier qui a vu ses commandes en
ligne se multiplier par deux sens en
deux ans on a on a bien travaillé
c'est vraiment on fait partie des
métiers qui s'en sortent bien et puis
j'ai même rembauché deux personnes mois
de janvier et février dernier parce
qu'en fait on travaille beaucoup le
maître chocolatier est l'un des cinq
artisans en france à fabriquer lui-même
son chocolat en transformant les fèves
de cacao importé du cameroun avec la
confédération du chocolatier christophe
bertrand a attribué le label chocolatier
engagé à 100 cacao on oblige la présence
de femmes au conseil d'administration
parce que notamment l'afrique ce sont
les femmes qui font avancer le monde
on oblige l'epargne salariale est
évidemment on demande la fermentation du
cacao aux coopératives parce que c'est
ça qui fait que le chocolat du goût il y
à un mois christophe bertrand est en
colombie où il a ramené des échantillons
d'une variété de cacao rare de criollo
ce chocolat en tablette ou en palais
sera désormais proposé en boutiques
d'ici une semaine
parlons golf à présent avec un nouveau
portrait il y a peu de temps livre
chinoise charlotte liothier a remporté
l'une de ses plus belles victoires sur
le circuit international
en gagnant les internationaux d'italie
dame
la joueuse de saint nom
la bretèche veut continuer sa
progression à presque 22 ans pour entrer
dans le cercle des meilleures joueuses
du circuit dans les prochaines années
reportage de michael almy d'euros à 21
ans elle fait partie des golfeuses à
suivant cette année 2021 charlotte
liothier vient de remporter les
internationaux d'italie dame ce 21 mars
victoire importante dans sa jeune
carrière c'est une victoire qui m'a
procuré beaucoup d'émotion parce que
parce que c'était pas une victoire qui
était qui a été annoncé avant et je me
suis vraiment battu pour pour gagner et
et quand on travaille beaucoup qu'on se
bat et que là
l'accomplissement de gagner ça arrive
c'est magnifique
en soulevant la coupe charles auto
liothier c'est sûrement remémorer ces
dix dernières années de golf à haut
niveau
la sportive a débuté sur les greens à
l'âge de 12 ans à la réunion avant de
quitter son île en 2014 pour rejoindre
la métropole
aujourd'hui la golfeuse s'épanouit dans
cet écrin saint nom la bretèche depuis
plus de deux ans c'est un club que je ne
connaissais pas du tout et honnêtement
mai
auquel je tiens beaucoup maintenant
parce que tout le monde est gentil avec
moi depuis toujours
les infrastructures sont bien il ya deux
par course et c'est vraiment bien pour
pouvoir s'entraîner parce qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de golf qui ont des
parcours
il ya des zones d'entraînement qui sont
quand même très bien et qui sont très
bien entretenus des infrastructures de
haut niveau qui vont lui permettre
d'accomplir l'un de ses premiers
objectifs passé professionnel en fin
d'année une première étape pour viser
ses plus grands rêves numéro 1 mondiale
parce que parce que bah c'est un peu
dans ma tête c'est un peu un objectif à
un rêve aussi surtout c'est d'avoir plus
personne devant soi et désire bas je
suis la plus forte du monde pendant un
temps mais je le suis et c'est vraiment
un rêve
autres objectifs envisagés dans les
prochaines années par charlotte liothier
les jeux olympiques et pourquoi pas ceux
de 2024 ou golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
à 21 ans l'avenir lui appartient pour
refermer cette fuite week-end comme
chaque semaine votre rendez-vous en
partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
collectif qui décrypte les déclarations
publiques des personnalités politiques
on écoute vincent couronne docteur en
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin et fondateur des surligneurs
plus les jours passent plus l'attention
de l'élection présidentielle qui aura
lieu en mai 2022 se fait sentir plus les
candidats potentiels ou déclarés
aiguisent leurs arguments il y en a 1
d'ailleurs qui aurait pu aiguiser un peu
plus sa proposition c'est le député
européen europe ecologie les verts
yannick jadot
que propose-t-il une tva à zéro pour
cent sur les produits bio afin d'inciter
les français à consommer plus
responsable et soutenir une filière
d'avenir
sauf que cette promesse serait bien
difficile à tenir car depuis 1977
les taux de tva font l'objet d'une
harmonisation européenne
le but limiter la concurrence fiscale
entre les états membres et que certains
états se transforme en grands
supermarchés à bas prix au détriment des
autres la france peut toujours décider
de son dos mais elle doit respecter
certains seuils européens en deçà
desquels elle ne peut descendre il y un
seuil notamment pour les produits de
base dans lequel d'ailleurs on peut
mettre les produits bio ce seuil c'est
5%
xavier bertrand tenait un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle avait proposé
de le faire pour les produits de
première nécessité si on veut donc
descendre en dessous des 5%
il faut donc réviser la directive
européenne sur la tva
et pour cela convaincre les autres états
membres et le parlement européen
rien d'impossible dans 2018 l'union
européenne a révisé cette directive de
77 pour aligner le taux de tva de la
presse en ligne sur celui des
publications papier dans un souci de
promotion du pluralisme de la presse
donc pour aiguiser sa proposition
yannick jadot devrait donc précisé que
lui président il ne serait pas seul à
décider
sinon tout ça n'aura été qu'un coup
d'épée dans l'eau
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h en direct dans le 7-8
journal présenté par grégory canale et
d'ici là je souhaite une très bonne
soirée un très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]